by now we've all seen what happened at
the capitol riots on january 6th
and we now have a pretty good idea of
what precipitated those
events the house is moving forward with
impeachment and articles of impeachment
are likely to pass though at this point
it's unclear at what point the senate
will
take up the articles of impeachment and
actually try the president and that
could last well into
president-elect biden's first term but
what we do know is that based on the
drafts of the impeachment articles that
we've already seen
it looks like article number one will be
charging president trump
with incitement to riot now incitement
to riot is an actual crime but it also
has a colloquial meaning as well
so the question is is president trump
guilty
of an incitement to riot
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a first amendment lawyer because
president trump is facing serious
allegations specifically with respect to
incitement to
starting or fomenting a riot now
incitement
has several different meanings
incitement is actually a limit
on free speech it's something that's not
protected by the first amendment
and incitement is also an actual crime
generally codified in every state
in the country and in federal law and
the district of columbia
and those criminal laws tend to hew
pretty closely to the constitutional
limit
as defined by the supreme court and of
course incitement is also a moral
judgment that is apart from both its
constitutional and criminal meaning but
let's take a step back
because when most people talk about
incitement they're talking about its
basis
in first amendment law and as you
probably know
the first amendment's protections extend
to individual and collective speech
as one court put it that are in pursuit
of a wide variety of political social
economic
educational religious and cultural ends
the supreme court interpreting the first
amendment generally protects
free speech unless it falls within one
of a few narrow categories
of unprotected speech things that we
define as
true threats or sometimes incitement
the court applies different levels of
scrutiny to different kinds of speech
and when the speech is of a political
and ideological nature
the court considers it to be a core of
the first amendment
you can imagine that arguably political
speech receives the most
protections and the most benefit of the
doubt when you're analyzing it under the
first amendment
and political speech almost always
receives the highest level of scrutiny
by the courts in other words
the court is almost always trying to
bend over backwards to protect
political speech so what is incitement
this category of
speech that is not protected well in the
landmark case of brandenburg vs ohio the
supreme court held that the first
amendment protects speakers who advocate
the use of force or
violating the law except where such
advocacy is
directed to inciting or producing
imminent lawless action
and is likely to incite or produce such
action
that's the key test the defendant in
that case was clarence brandenburg who
addressed a gathering of ku klux klan
members in a field in hamilton county
ohio in 1969.
a journalist recorded brandenburg saying
that he was concerned the federal
government was going to suppress the
white caucasian race
he made derogatory statements against
black people and jewish people
he said that the klan may need to get
quote revengeance on the federal
government if it continued doing things
that he viewed as racist against white
people
and brandenburg said that clan members
were preparing a march on washington dc
for july
4th police arrested brandenburg for
violating an ohio law which made it a
crime to
advocate the duty necessity or propriety
of crime sabotage
or unlawful methods of terrorism as a
means of accomplishing industrial or
political reform
and he was convicted at the trial court
level now brandenburg fought his
conviction all the way to the supreme
court where he argued that the ohio law
was unconstitutional at the time of
brandenburg's conviction the court had
been using the clear and present danger
text to determine when speech
constituted
incitement the supreme court unanimously
actually overturned brandenburg's
conviction
and issued a new test for all future
restrictions of speech on the basis of
incitement
and that test is what we just talked
about it's the imminent danger test
in other words the imminent danger test
is speech that's advocating violence and
can only be punished
where quote such advocacy is directed to
inciting or producing imminent lawless
action
and is likely to incite or produce such
action
and in that case according to the
supreme court brandenburg's speech did
not invite his followers to do anything
except
march on washington dc at a later date
which you can imagine is
generally protected speech now the
supreme court continued to develop the
imminent lawless action test in a case
called hex versus indiana where
it overturned the conviction of an
anti-war demonstrator in bloomington
indiana
there the defendant gregory hess stood
on a curve and yelled
we'll take the [ __ ] street again or
later now i'm not gonna bleep that out
because
that is the speech that's involved and
you can't understand these cases unless
you know
what's actually at issue in these cases
but the court said that hess of speech
could reasonably be construed in a
number of different ways
maybe he was advocating illegal activity
later but certainly not imminently
or maybe he was trying to tell the crowd
to stand down in either case
his arrest infringed on his first
amendment right to speak his mind
now the brainenberg test was also not
satisfied in a 1982 case involving the
naacp's practice of writing down the
names of people
who violated boycotts of certain white
businesses
the organization would read the names of
the people who broke the boycotts aloud
at meetings and although one of their
members said that
if we catch any of you going in any of
them racist stores we're going to break
your damn neck
the court held that the statement was
not a direct threat or an incitement to
violence
in that case there was no evidence that
the man quote authorized ratified or
directly threatened the acts of violence
now although there haven't been a whole
lot of other incitement cases
a 2015 case bears mentioning in bible
believers vs wayne county
a divided full panel of the sixth
circuit which is one step below the
supreme court
ruled that wayne county michigan
officials violated the first amendment
rights of a christian evangelical group
when they removed them from an arab
festival the police removed the group to
protect them from an audience that was
hostile to the group's views
the christian group made statements like
islam is a religion of blood and murder
or turn or burn or your prophet is a
pedophile
the evangelical christians walked
through the angry crowd and although
they were the ones being assaulted the
cops kicked them out
punishing them for their speech rather
than punishing the crowd for breaking
the law
now this case was about whether the
first amendment protected unpopular
speech and it clearly does
but it also touched briefly on the
incitement doctrine the court emphasized
that quote the hostile reaction
of a crowd does not transform protected
speech into
incitement this is what is often
referred to as a heckler's veto
and here the words that the speakers
said weren't advocating violence or
crime they were expressing an opinion
that another religion was
violent and while potentially offensive
this was still considered protected
speech
we're not here to cause a problem it's
just when we talk about jesus
this is what happens and in a different
case the sixth circuit relied heavily on
the bible believers case
when they had to assess trump's
culpability for assaults that happened
at one of his rallies
oh was that president trump was accused
of incitement before
yes he was if you thought the capital
riots were an isolated incident
you haven't been paying attention what
happened is donald trump was actually
sued in 2016 for starting a riot
on the election trail in 2016 he held a
rally in louisville the
rally was organized by his campaign and
during that rally then-candidate trump
said
five times to have protesters removed
get him the hell out get him out don't
hurt him in response
members of the audience assaulted pushed
and shoved these people
a trump supporter punched one of them in
the stomach two other trump supporters
participated in assaults and the victims
sued the perpetrators and they also sued
president trump for inciting a riot
at his campaign event now kentucky law
makes it a misdemeanor to incite a riot
a person is guilty of inciting to riot
when he incites or urges
five or more persons to create or engage
in a riot
riot is defined as a public disturbance
involving an assemblage of five or more
persons
which by tumultuous and violent conduct
creates grave danger of damage
or injury to property or persons now on
appeal
the sixth circuit court of appeals ruled
that donald trump did not incite a riot
by his words
trump wasn't telling everyone to commit
a crime why because the court reasoned
he followed his statement with get him
out of here but don't hurt him don't
hurt him
so you could assume that he meant that
the protesters should be ejected
but not that the tumultuous or violent
conduct should be used to eject them
and hurt them though you can see how
highly context dependent this is
this could also have been interpreted as
a rhetorical hypothesis or
antiphrasis where by raising the issue
even in the negative
he's actually implying the positive to
hurt the bystanders and the protesters
now the brandenburg standard is closely
tracked by the kentucky statute
however the court held that even if
president trump's conduct
incited a riot under kentucky law the
first amendment would
bar the claim and that's because for
speech to be
outside of the protection of the first
amendment it has to actually
encourage violence or lawlessness but
like the ohio klansman case the court
found that trump's speech did not
encourage violence or lawlessness
even implicitly the court distinguished
between speech that tends to encourage
violence generally
and speech that advocated for listeners
to take specific
unlawful action and here the court cited
the hess and bible believers cases to
make their point
hess told his audience what he intended
to do but he didn't advocate for them to
do anything and in the bible believers
case they were expressing their belief
about
the islamic religion but that didn't
necessarily give the listeners the right
to break the law
because they were mad about it and under
first amendment law
words generally can't be punished simply
because they tend to evoke a certain
response
in the listener so with that in mind
let's look at what president trump
actually said
on january 6 right before the capital
riots knowing what we now know about
incitement and the brandenburg test
let's apply it to president trump's
speech president trump used the word
fight more than 20 times during his
rally speech on january 6.
was that incitement well the first
question is what did he mean by fight
did he mean the crowd should actually
fight or was it a metaphor that they
need to
fight things in the abstract consider
the statement
and we fight we fight like hell and if
you don't fight like hell
you're not gonna have a country anymore
this sounds scary in light of what
eventually happened the storming of the
capital that left at least five people
dead
but he also doesn't say punch people or
break windows or fight the police
specifically or even
fight democrats specifically he never
even said anything like he did in
kentucky back in 2016.
get him out of here instead he says
we're going to walk down
to the capitol
and we're going to cheer on our brave
senators and congressmen and women
here again president trump doesn't tell
the audience to do anything but fight
and cheer which
can be taken in multiple directions in a
democracy in the context of an election
campaign
it's pretty easy to view this as
fighting to get elected and not giving
up regardless of
what you think of whether the election
in 2020 was run perfectly well
or if it was fraught with fraud you can
imagine that this
is sort of an abstract statement about
what he wants to be accomplished
and the here the congress was actually
meeting to finalize the election results
but what about this other phrase we have
come to demand that congress
do the right thing and only count the
electors who have been lawfully
slated lawfully slated
i know that everyone here will soon be
marching over to the capitol building
to peacefully and patriotically make
your voices heard
it doesn't seem like he's advocating for
specific violence or trying to encourage
specific people to break the law at
least
not based on the explicit text again
context matters and
there's certainly lots of subtext to
read into this and at the time the only
person that president trump wanted to
explicitly break the law was mike pence
but on the other hand even though
president trump was advocating for
something to happen that
really couldn't happen overturning
biden's election he specifically says he
wants his followers to march
to the capitol and if we're at least
looking at the literal meaning of
president trump's words he's saying that
people
should march to the capitol which is a
core
first amendment protected activity
generally speaking
but what about this but we're going to
try and give
our republicans the weak ones because
the strong
ones don't need any of our help we're
going to try and give them
the kind of pride and boldness that they
need to take back
our country so let's walk down
pennsylvania avenue here encouraging
people to have pride and boldness is
probably too vague to imply
violence especially when he also told
them to be peaceful
and what it comes down to is that
president trump asked people to march
on the capitol to his audience president
trump's words are probably considered
incredibly authoritative the president
said to go to the capitol so we're going
to go there with him and in fact
that's exactly what happened when
president trump's speech was over
they pretty much all marched towards the
capitol but
still president trump didn't tell them
to fight police or to storm the capital
or to even trespass
on the other hand context is incredibly
important president trump
started his speech at roughly 12 noon
and it wasn't until 12 30 that the
crowds descended on the capital
by about 1 pm the crowds were already
pushing into the outer barricades at the
capitol
around 1 10 pm president trump ends his
speech which includes line we're going
to the capitol
we're going to walk down pennsylvania
avenue i love pennsylvania avenue
and we're going to the capitol and if
you don't fight
you're not going to have a country
anymore of course his speech was given
at the white house in the ellipse which
is about a mile and a half
away from the capital so you can imagine
that
a court might consider that this would
be a reasonable cooling off period
that's
a pretty far distance to travel on foot
in terms of whether you're inciting a
crowd to do something but
by 1 30 the crowd had moved from the
white house to the capitol
and by about 215 they had breached the
capital itself
and were on the inside with all of the
congress members
but things got a lot harrier at 2 24 pm
with rioters actually inside the capital
actively looking for members of congress
and vice president pence
presumably to do them great physical
harm president trump tweets out
mike pence didn't have the courage to do
what should have been done to protect
our country and our constitution
giving states a chance to certify a
corrected set of facts not the
fraudulent or inaccurate ones
which they were asked to previously
certify usa demands
the truth but then president trump
follows that up at 2 38 p.m stating via
tweet
please support our capitol police and
law enforcement they are truly on the
side of our country stay peaceful
though shortly thereafter at 3 15 pm
ashley babbitt is shot and killed
which is at the same time that president
trump tweets out i'm asking for everyone
the u.s capitol to remain peaceful no
violence
remember we are the party of law and
order respect the law and our great men
and women in blue
thank you now by 405 pm president-elect
biden goes on tv to demand an end to the
siege
borders on sedition and it must
end now and by 4 17
pm president trump released his now
famous tv address
calling for calm which he has later
repudiated we have to have peace
so this is a set of facts that honestly
could go either way
incitement is a kind of legal unicorn
it's much rarer than rico or
entrapment and almost always incitement
is used to try to silence protected
speech
but this whole situation comes about as
close as you'll ever see to a true case
of incitement it really could go either
way
but at the same time we are squarely
looking down the barrel of
generally protected political speech and
i think that if
a court especially the supreme court
would look at the actual language here
i think they are going to look at this
kind of case with about as much scrutiny
as they're ever going to apply and
probably give
the speaker of what is arguably
political speech
every benefit of the doubt which makes a
conviction for a criminal case of
incitement
extremely unlikely but the question
remains
does this mean that president trump is
off the hook because his words might not
meet the actual
technical legal standard for criminal
incitement
well i'm here to tell you that that is
merely the beginning of the story it is
not the end of the story because
impeachment and removal
is always on the table i've covered this
before so i'll only touch on this
briefly
the legal standard for impeachment is in
article 2 section 4 which says a
president can be impeached
for treason bribery and other high
crimes and misdemeanors
as you know from my past videos on
president trump's first impeachment
sources on how the terms high crimes and
misdemeanors should be defined are
sparse
but some legal scholars like jonathan
turley are adamant that this means that
congress can only impeach
and remove a person if they've committed
an actual crime as defined in criminal
law
i think this is absolutely wrong and the
vast majority of legal scholars agree
that
an actual technical legal criminal
violation is not necessary for
impeachment
no matter what political and
trump-supporting flags like alan
dershowitz and jonathan turley say
now the founders were concerned about
offenses committed against the country
itself
by people in high places of authority
therefore the term high crimes
doesn't mean a high felony like murder
or kidnapping instead
the phrase high crime implies an offense
by a person in a high place of authority
just like it did in
england the constitution also says a
public official can be impeached for a
misdemeanor now in american criminal law
a misdemeanor is a crime punishable by
less than one year in jail
but misdemeanors are crimes like petty
theft possession of marijuana disorderly
conduct and public intoxication
if we use the standard legal definition
of misdemeanor and criminal law
that would expose federal officials to
removal from very basic infractions
and that's probably not what the
founding fathers want the founding
fathers understood that misdemeanor was
a way to punish
malversation in office which is an
obsolete phrase but it basically means
that it's corrupt behavior by a person
in a position of public trust
and not for nothing in the 1868
impeachment of andrew johnson
one of the improved articles of
impeachment was on numerous occasions
president johnson quote made
with loud voice certain intemperate
inflammatory and scandalous harangues
and did therein utter loud threats and
bitter menaces against congress in the
law's united states
duly enacted thereby amid the cries
jeers and laughter of the multitudes
then assembled and within bearing in
other words
president johnson was impeached for his
purely political speech
something that is absolutely not
criminal in any way shape or form
and there are plenty who believe that
the president incited a riot i think not
in a technical legal sense
but in a moral and ethical sense like
lawyer george conway who concluded quote
working together trump and his family
and his friends used the rhetoric of
violence
of armed uprising and that is what they
got
and i think conway is probably correct
in the moral sense this was a pro-trump
uprising and it was predictable
since there were threats posted all over
social media and
the president's words were at the very
least unbelievably negligent and
reckless
and might have even been intended to
provoke some sort of violent response
it was certainly fomented supported and
provoked by president trump
even if not legally incited under the
brandenburg standard
but under that very standard we have to
look at the meaning of president trump's
actual words
and the actual likelihood of provoking
that violence but
on the other hand congress can look at
the events of that entire day
and decide that president trump breached
the public's trust not in a
technical or legalistic sense but in a
political sense
because not only was president trump
enjoying the mob's siege
of the capitol as it happened but even
as the mob turned violent
president trump was busy calling on mike
pence and senator tuberville and senator
lee
asking each one to be sure to delay the
vote to certify biden's victory
and it appears that when the mayor of dc
asked for help
president trump refused to send in the
dc national guard
apparently maryland tried to send help
as well but governor hogan
said that the pentagon inexplicably
refused
between the president's acts of actually
contributing to the right whether or not
that
meets the legal standard of incitement
between his acts of trying to make
things
worse to let the capital burn and
between his acts
of actually trying to literally subvert
the democratic process
and prevent the certification of his
political rival as the next president of
the united states
those can contribute to an impeachable
offense
one that could lead to the president
being removed regardless of whether it
meets
any legal or technical definition as one
legal commentator put it impeachment is
a political solution to a political
problem it should be reserved for truly
heinous behavior that harms the country
but quote this wasn't technically a
statutory crime should play
exactly zero role in that analysis in
other words
if this is not impeachable conduct
nothing is